all right super loyal to you she's not
doing anything else on the side she only
loves him Mars respects you there's no
[__] [__] and she stays loyal to you you
must have to leverage as the man
that you if you leave her her life is
gonna suck significantly more so what
she gonna do she's gonna be what I'm
telling you outright the best when
they're stepping on eggshells not trying
to get you mad or get broken up with I
think that's been three days a week away
from your woman she's gonna be sucking
another dick in like two months
three days a week what
wait wait wait wait wait I was just
thinking of my parents I'm like and I
know they always make fun of me because
I have I have family experience right
it's like doesn't count I guess my dad
would go away for a while and my parents
didn't cheat on each other and I'm like
so if you have no self-control that if
you don't see a man you have to see him
like you can't go three days without
seeing it what you're otherwise then
you're gonna like what what type of
women are you speaking to that's my
question